i want to mention you have a podcast uh
and a lot of people have podcasts i
really love
your podcast uh the the title is i
way and um it it feels like a very
important
topic uh to to be talking about these
days not just the normal chit chat
uh can you tell us what i way is all
about for anyone who hasn't heard it
so i way was a social movement i started
two years ago to change the way that
people measure themselves so by their
inequalities rather than pounds and
kilos in the weighing scale but it has
evolved over the last two years to be a
kind of
full mental health movement and movement
against shame and so
aside from my my penis shaming that just
happened
i don't believe in shame i clearly don't
have any
not a trace left i
am bankrupt to give and so
i wanted to make this podcast a mental
health podcast where we would explore
all the kind of most stigmatized topics
and have people from all backgrounds
whether they are celebrities
or they are experts or scientists etc
come on
and talk in a very demystifying
destigmatizing way about things that
everyone's going through
we just don't talk about it enough and i
had planned to do this podcast before
the pandemic hit
but it just came at a time where people
didn't have access to therapists they
didn't have access to
each other and so it's been uh strangely
helpful i think some people and just
hearing that
you are so not alone in all of the
things that you're experiencing
this speaks to something that i think
about a lot
both of us know a lot of celebrities and
we're accustomed to
people thinking that celebrities
um they take a quick glance and they say
oh this person's
uh they don't have anything to worry
about and um
they must love themselves and it's been
like a personal crusade of mine
to say uh pardon my french but like
everybody's [ __ ] up and and and
um so many people would look at you and
say
this person you know how could she talk
about shame she's so beautiful when
of course you could talk about that
you're a human being you have the same
experiences as everyone else and so
that's probably something demystifying
that i think is really important
yeah i mean i grew up with just such
glossy role models
and i didn't know anything i didn't even
know about people making mistakes or
they're you know growing and i never saw
anyone grow in public it was just such a
glossy veneer of [ __ ] and so it made
me feel so isolated in all of my
experiences because i've suffered with
my mental health issues for 20 years or
so
and so and so my family members i
thought there was something so wrong
with us i didn't know because
i didn't have any transparent role
models who told the truth and so
for better or for worse i'm determined
to be as transparent as i can and
sometimes that
leads to some questionable moments
publicly
but it also means that i'm being willing
to be the anti-celebrity
and just be vulnerable and human and
flawed right
yeah other kids can know that it's okay
if you like
wasn't deaf right you have to do better
and so i think that i've tried to
i tried to be what i didn't have when i
was younger
and uh and i'm just it's a social
experiment i don't know how it's going
well i uh we've been talking about maybe
i'll come on your podcast because i have
uh a lot of things to talk about in this
arena
um i'd love to i also think and i want
to know what you think about this but i
think that
artists in particular are almost more
likely to be
messed up you know there's something i
think in you
there has to be something in you that
would drive you to do such a weird job
and to need the approval and applause
and the love of other people i think
there is something inherently
like there's a not to turn this into a
therapy session but i think there's a
little hole inside of all of us i also
think
artistry comedy uh song lyrics etc
i think that they are a way of a kid who
doesn't know how to communicate
uh learning how to communicate with the
world i think in itself it speaks to
some sort of like kink or damage in
there that you know this is how we
process
it to make other people happy definitely
i've been saying this for 27 years
my nightly comedy show is a cry for help
[Laughter]
and instead of anybody saying how can we
help you uh
they say great we're wrapped for the
night let's do another one tomorrow
um so uh yeah but maybe this will help
really get the word out that
i'm in desperate need of uh of
assistance
you